EIGHT THREE-POINT MAKES IN THAT
QUARTER.
S CREATED WITH THE
DRIBBLE AND THE FINISH   RIM. G
>> Stan: GIANNIS IS MISSING, BUT
RIGHT BACK UP ONNT WHERE HE SAI
WILL BE IN AND OUT OF THE  KEVIF
TRYING TO LEAD BEEN A LUCKY
CHARM AND GOT EXTRA
SHOTS WITH SARBA WITH THE WHIST
GOOD PERIMETER DEFENDER, KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
ROOK LOPEZ
>> Lisa: WILEP.
>> Vince: OLD RAY ALLEN, MAN. M
HE'S GOT IT RIGHT.
THESAURUS.COM.
WORK IT ONVE BEEN GOOD
UP 5,
TALKED ABOUT WITH PAUL.R GUYS C
THE THREE-POINT SHOT.
SEPARATOR.
THERE'S THE SHIMMY START FROM
THREE-POINT TERRITORY, 34-35 MI,
TH
>> Lisa: WES,
BUCKET.
>> Marques: JUST KIND OF
ANTICIPATE WHERE THE
MIDDLETON FOR A WHILE WAS ONE OF
THE MORE UNDERRATED GUYS IN TO E
WHEN HE'S GOT DO WHAT I CAN.
KNOW, TOLD HER THAT HE WASEING .
YOU CAN'T LEAVEOVERTIME WIN AGA
OFFENSIVE IT.
MIDDLETON LETS IT FRARA HALF.
AND GOTTEN HIMSELF IN A HIS FIR
BUCKET.
0 FOR 2.
KNOCKS THAT ONE DOWN.
ANOTHERR
>> HE IS AN ALL-STAR FOR A
REASON.S OUT TONIGHT WITH
ANKLE KHRIS MIDDLETON WITH
THE TOUGH LONGCLOSE-OUT ON HUER
>> Zora: KHRIS F A THE
BASKETBALL BACK.
HE RIGHT HERE GOING
TO GET CUTSCORE.
>> Zora: QUICK PASS AH
THE BIGS ALWAYS TEND TO LURK
WITH THE OPPONENT JERSEY ON A.
>> Zora: KHRIS DEMETRIUS.
ITH THE
STRENGTH AND
AS WELL.
DOING
CALLER MOBLEY.
>> Austin: THE WAY THEY'REIT, R?
HE GOT OUT OF THE GATE SO
POINT.
0 FOR 5 TO BEGIN phen: NICE BAL.
GRAYSON GOT A PIECE
LOT OF PICK-AND-ROLLS, BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IT WON'T RESUL AND A
SPACE.
MIDDLETON FROM UP TOP.
POSSIBLE G GOOOODD
LOLOOKOK..
>>>> L Lisisa:a: GO.
MIDDLETON, BASELINE, THAT WAS
TOUGH.
>> Jim: THE THING THAT'SRNES, T
ASSIGNMENT ON
>> Zora: TWO-MAN GAME.
H OFF OF
BARNES.